So we have seen in the previous quiz that the 1-bit predictor can
not really predict well the pattern N N T that repeats.
We will see that a 2-bit history will be successfully predicting this pattern.
How does a 2-bit history predictor work? Same as before. We take the PC and
we index into the branch history table from which we get an entry. Now,
however, the entry we get has five pieces. It has
two bits of history. So these are the last two outcomes of this branch.
And then we have 4 times a 2-bit counter. One for each possible history.
So with two bits we will index into this array of counters and
use the appropriate counter for the given history. So as you can see,
the overall cost of this predictor now is 2 bits of history plus 4 times 2,
so it ends up costing us ten bits per branch. Instead of going through a lengthy
example of how this works, when we try to predict this pattern,
let's try to figure it out. The sequence of outcomes is N, N, T.
N, N, T etc. When we are seeing the outcome of T,
and trying to predict it, that is we are trying to predict what will become T,
our two bit history will be zero, zero.
It's saying that the last two outcomes we have seen, have been both not taken.
This history will make us use this counter here.
So that counter, which we'll call counter number zero, will be counting up.
When we are trying to predict this particular outcome our history will be zero,
one. We will be using counter number one. And
we will decrement it because we are seeing a non-taken decision.
When we are trying to predict this the history will be one, zero. This is,
corresponds to counter number two, which will also be decremented. For this,
now we will again use the history of zero zero, because the last two
outcomes have been not taken. This means that the counter number zero,
because of this taken decision, will be incremented. And so on. As you can see,
counter zero always counts up, so very soon it will start predicting taken.
Which means every time we see a history of 00,
we will start predicting strong taken. Counter one keeps counting down, so
very soon after seeing this history of 01, we will predict strong not taken, and
similarly counter two is always counting down. So
very soon we will start predicting not taken when we see a history of one zero.
As you can see what's now going to happen is pretty much this counter zero here,
will start to predict strong taken. Counter one will start to
predict strong not taken, and counter two is going to predict strong not taken.
Counter number three, which is the last counter we have,
actually never gets used. Because we never see a history of one, one.
That would mean that we have seen a taken followed by a taken,
which doesn't happen in this particular pattern. So,
as you can see, this predictor starts being a perfect predictor after awhile,
after these counters have been appropriately modified depending on
their starting state. So, unlike a single bit history predictor,
a 2-bit history can predict this pattern accurately.